you have a young boy with Down syndrome
in the middle of nowhere all right well
while you've been doing paperwork we've
been doing something called living this
movie was incredible when you are making
this did you sort of have an inkling
that it was gonna be magic yes yes you
know what was it what was it like for
you to be part of this unfortunately
there's not a lot of movies where
someone with Down syndrome can lead the
movie and make it so special what was
that like
most people most people just want to be
like me about what everything about what
I do I would say citement energy and did
you go for hour-long things and and I
just feel like this to do it and just
get it done this and this movie for a
lot of people see maybe we could be
friends in bodies bro dogs what do you
feel like you guys learned about
yourselves working with each other he
softened me yeah he softened me coming
in I was quite twisted and let's let
that wild timing because the sirens it's
not me they yeah but he he just softened
me like I just remember when I first met
him feeling like vigilant about like
protecting him and then I got very that
way with him and that he was really like
vocal about not having me be that and
then he was very protective over me yeah
like I got quite vulnerable to this
shoot it's funny because you did say you
felt very fragile making this yeah and
there's stuff like you know me and him
on a boat where he's really like my
guardian yeah and I don't know if I
don't like allowed anybody else to get
into my life that way wiggling in my
heart like that ever I've never had
anybody like that in my life especially
dudes like I'm anti alpha male you know
like I have a real aversion to it so he
is an alpha male but his way is quite
like cotton soft you know he is an alpha
male
he leads the whole set he's like a he's
a galvanized ER and a coach and like he
does lead the charge he's the one who
gives the speech every night but I don't
know if Ida relented to that kind of
energy unless it came from a person with
this kind of heart yeah so yeah I'd say
I'd say are you getting bored no okay so
I see yeah I just say like yes often
it's a lifetime friendship yeah sure
yeah you need a name oh yeah a lot of
awards season buzz already for this what
would that type of recognition mean to
each of you guys it's gotta be a little
flattering right I mean this movie is it
has all the different makings of that
type of of a film in my opinion cool
thank you for saying yeah I would like
to see that Zack yeah too bad it's on
the road oh yeah Shia you really go for
it with your roles but with this
especially it's like you really brought
the heart
can you speak to that a little bit yeah
I always say that this is the first time
like I didn't like my plan didn't work
I'd be honest with you
like if it wasn't for them that then I
wouldn't be in this movie really my role
is on them and like I leaned into them
and they held me down so I tribute them
with everything that works in this movie
and and I showed up for that and for
them and they showed up for me and for
the same thing yeah I'm not any more or
less just I guess I was I never been
this open or it's never it's never like
usually have a break even if you go
heavy you know 24 hours a day and you're
prepping you always get like some kind
of like respite but my rest bits were
always with them I'd always want to be
around them so yeah there was never any
cut you know we were really immersed in
it hey what's the one party no not party
and there's a lot of improv happening -
yeah that I mean that comes from
from Zach you have a an ability to kind
of just go wherever you want with your
feelings and please scene yeah yep
and we just have had to follow and it
was really fun yeah I would say I'm a
great time because I'm I do love dancing
with her and she deep secret love
dancing and what it's only a very good
time and just do out on the wrapping and
SIA we're done watching ads about while
we are doing then but just love doing
out together yeah he's kind of a wild
card you're like you don't really know
what you're gonna get when they call
action so you just got to be ready to
catch whatever he's gonna throw at you
and that I think is part of the reason
for all the performances in the film it
kind of makes everyone all the guards
come down and on every any plan that you
had is just gone and so you
I think perhaps come across super
vulnerable because you are no we're not
gonna hop on your little raft and cruise
around down the ribs do you want to go
down memory lane a little bit it's been
20 years since you made your big screen
debut crazy in Alabama with your mom
yeah you guys ever talked about working
together again we may have done some
things together that might be a secret
oh really
can you give us a hint I can't okay that
was a hint that was a hint that was a
finish it yeah
what about you your mom and your grandma
like you would have not thought about
that okay I don't know yeah we'd need to
have like a therapist phone call I think
there that would be amazing though that
is hilarious and then
Shaya going down memory lane alright
beans even Stevens were you guys fans of
even Stevens you you still are
yeah yeah yeah me yeah I was damn I
still am I still in him too and she ever
think about bringing that back no no
you're the closed chapter
no I mean I love ah yeah I mean I love
doing it was a lot of fun but no I
haven't thought about that
Hey bang bang ah scuse me we got it
right here
yeah this is it this is a raft strong
Disney cruise cruise that will be there
right I do want to show you something so
we found your first ever Premier
interview somebody you really feel kotas
it's a it's your Shia same time so if
you could just play yes at my first
movie era
it's like the first time it's the first
time like a rookie this nervousness no
already for nothing dude I'm 16 I live
right over there I hope I get used to it
we're not like a little pretentious
you're really amazing so on it
his face is like I don't know what I'm
doing here I mean you're amazing he's
like what person it but whoa that's true
Wow yeah you were nervous he's still get
nervous but most of these interviews are
like yeah I'm really excited to be here
and he's just like oh next time I might
sit down I'm gonna do these you - no I -
yeah I'm really excited to be here I'm
totally fine that's what my
[Music]